JURY.
HE DIEPUGH IN 1946.
>> IN WASHINGTON THE BRAIN
TRUSTS IN THE REPUBLICAN AND
DEMOCRAT PARTIES ARE PLANNING
THEIR MIDTERM ELECTIONS IN
NOVEMBER.
TONIGHT ON CAPITOL HILL WE LOOK
AT THE MESSAGES.
THE PARTIES ARE TRYING TO
CONVEY.
>> THE ROAD MAP THAT HAS PROVEN
SUCCESSFUL FOR REPUBLICANS IN
SENATE PRIMARIES SO FAR TRASH
TALK THE INCUMBENT DEMOCRAT.
>> A SENATOR WORKING WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> OHIO WILL MOVE FORWARD WITH
THE TRUMP AGENDA.
>> GOP CANDIDATES ARE TOUTING
TAX REFORM, REGULAR TORY ROLL
BACKS, AND FLOOD OF CONSERVATIVE
JUDGES TO COURT ROOMS.
>> YOU LOOK AT THE SUPREME COURT
NOMINATIONS.
OUR JUDGES ARE FILLING THE
CORRECTS.
MAKING GOOD DECISIONS BASED ON
THE CONSTITUTION.
>> SOME MIMIC TRUMP'S
ANTI-ESTABLISHMENT A PROEFRP.
LOOK AT MISSOURI.
>> THEY'RE FURIOUS THAT PUGH C
HAS FEATHERED THEIR OWN NEST AND
PEOPLE LIKE CLAIRE HAVE VOTED
FOR WAYS TO BENEFIT THEM.
>> DEMOCRATS DON'T THINK THEY
CAN CLAIM THE OUTSIDE THE BELT
WAY APPROACH ANYMORE AFTER WHAT
THEY CALL CONTROVERSIES OF THE
EPA, HUD, AND OMB.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BECOME
THE SWAMP.
>> THEY SAY THEY'RE A BETTER
DEAL TRYING TO DIMINISH THE
CROWN JEWEL, TAX REFORM.
>> NOW THE RISING GAS PRICES
WILL CANCEL OUT THE 2018
CONSUMPTION WORST OF TAX CUTS.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S NAME IS BEING
USED TO MODIVATE BASE VOTERS.
>> THE BEST THING WE CAN DO TO
STOP THE WORST PART ABOUT THE
TRUMP AGENDA IS TO WIN THE 2018
ELECTIONS.
>> IN STATES TRUMP WON DEMOCRATS
CAN'T ALL RUN AGAINST HIM.
WHICH MEANS THE PARTY ISN'T
TOTALLY UNITED.
>> IN WEST VIRGINIA PEOPLE LIKE
DONALD TRUMP AND JOE.
WE WORK WELL TOGETHER.
>> THAT GOES TO SHOW YOU AS
STRATEGIES ARE BEING CRAFTED
EVEN LAW MAKERS CONSIDERED THE
MOST VULNERABLE ARE NOT ALL
ONBOARD WITH THE MESSAGES THE
NATIONAL LEADERS ARE SPENDING
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS